[Music]
hello hello hello hello welcome back to
RIF and wig riff and here we go y'all
and you know what time it is
oh yeah welcome back y'all to yo
absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
Christmas got a special one for you
coming live I got the chat going we're
gonna take calls well I'm not ready to
take calls I'm just gonna play a call
that I did hey with mister once again I
really appreciate everybody coming back
you know what it is all right yeah
what's up everybody welcome back to
riffing with Griffin
you know we're here
I don't know I I'm doing it like this
look I got a new overlay that's by mr.
Michael genese I believe is his last
name I know I'm not getting the [ __ ]
name right but welcome welcome back I'm
doing it live you know it's weird times
you know I'm just I'm weird I feel weird
as hell you know it's just I'm bored out
of my [ __ ] mind I gotta be honest
with you and it's just like it's hard to
keep the depression away I keep telling
y'all I just want you know I feel the
same way as all you guys feel out there
I mean it's it's tough you know what I
mean I mean it's just it's tough cuz
it's like every day you think okay maybe
this will be the day and then we just
get no information you know what I'm
saying like I get no information so I
I'm just sometimes I'm just in the house
I don't know what day it is
I don't know what time it is weekends
don't feel like weekends so it's just
like days and days running on and
running on this must be what jail feels
like and then you're not then I started
to realize like
I'm not even getting like I couldn't
find my genes like I wanted to go
outside cause it was raining that's
another thing California is like [ __ ]
y'all you need to stay inside we did we
got the virus and we got there the
freakin rain so it's like you look
outside like maybe I should go take a
walk and you don't even want to do that
you know what I mean
and what's up chat I see you guys I will
say hi as soon as I get the opportunity
just like you know just let me just run
through my random thoughts for a second
so I couldn't find my genes I'm not
wearing my watch you know it's like you
know you got like one pair of shoes that
you get to wear Ian like you're not
changing outfits you just kind of like
living and only because my girlfriend is
here like I'm taking a shower
I wouldn't even [ __ ] take a shower if
it wasn't for her so this [ __ ] is just
weird it starts to [ __ ] with your head
man so I I just doesn't you know we all
in this together
we all in this together and then it's
like this holiday is going on and it's
like you're Easter's out around the
corner right isn't Easter coming up like
I don't even know what's going like what
am I gonna do is Easter this Sunday like
I don't know what I'm doing for Easter
my mom has dementia so she don't even
care about that kind of stuff anymore
they used to be one of the things she
really cared about it was like Easter
and like a midnight mass for Christmas
and like those kinds of things she don't
even know now she didn't even know it
was my birthday yeah well that was the
one that really hurt that's the one that
like I really started to feel what was
going on with my mom I was like damn I
my mom doesn't know that it's my
birthday
you know what I mean I know we're not
showering so I'm just sitting here and
then you like check this thing out guys
I wanted to show you guys this thing
from the freaking mayor of Los Angeles
this [ __ ] is encouraging
snitching like look at this [ __ ] LA
mayor says snitch snitches get rewards
that they report neighbors what does
that mean report your neighbor like what
does that even mean is that like like
because we're supposed to be able to go
for walks we're supposed to be able to
go for essential items we're supposed to
be so who's sitting around determining
like what I'm doing I don't like this at
all people need to [ __ ] money
business you know like if anything you
need to come ask me first like yo I
don't even want that so what we gonna be
doing citizen's arrest me gonna be
walking out of people like yo what you
doing right now I'm walking [ __ ] what
[ __ ] are you doing it's none of your
damn business
you know what I mean it sucks dude I
just I just think that this this is just
feeding into the paranoia even more you
know I mean like this [ __ ] is ridiculous
you know it's like you know people get
the nosy neighbors gonna be all in your
damn business you know what you know I
could see the chat so what we gonna do
is mr. Jacob mr. Jacobs going on timeout
you know what I mean we do on timeout
[ __ ] and you can get lost that's how I
feel about it up in my chat right now we
go alive and you talking too much
nonsense in here you're going like in
these troubled times you really got to
come in here and just be [ __ ] like
what's the point of that like what is
the point
I guess people trying to see this is
that's a snitch right there he'll be a
snitch
yep that [ __ ] should be a snitch yeah
so I don't know if I agree with that
this whole this whole snitching thing is
just it just feels something it feels
weird you know what I mean so I don't
know well I mean what do you guys think
you know I mean let me get some
questions in here uh yeah of course the
whole snitch snitching and you know ask
some questions now cuz you're thirty
seconds behind and thanks for the super
chat for the people that in there right
now
I don't know guys so here's something
that I did something that I did do the
other day I want to show you guys that
yet something I did the other day is so
it was I'm not Jewish my girlfriend's
Jewish you know so I don't know well
peace - peace to all the Jews out there
what up Jews so I had the most hilarious
like people asked me from writing
material like are you are you know do I
have material are you looking for
material and I do have some material
because I had to zoom with my girlfriend
we're so we're on our couch
my couch and we zoom into her family
Seder you know like I don't even know I
didn't even know what a I didn't even
know what a seder was let me actually
look up what the hell it is say you know
Seder definition okay so here we go
I didn't even you know I really didn't
know what the hell it was so the Seder
definition is a Jewish ritual service
and ceremony dinner for the first night
or two nights of Passover yeah so
actually let's look at what the hell
Passover is just to get to full
definition the major Jewish Spring
Festival which commits commemorates the
liberation of the Israelites from Egypt
slavery lasting seven or eight days from
the fifteenth okay all right so you love
Apple Seder I'm looking at the chat to
chat is [ __ ] hilarious
so I'm sitting here so we sit down you
know I tried to do it right I put my
good webcam up I even got one of my
lights that I use and I put it so we're
on the couch I'm a girl she's kind of
she's not necessarily dressed up but I
could tell you know she she wore a bra
you know to me it was like had a nice
shirt on it was like it was cool and so
I had to like in the setup and this [ __ ]
was hilarious because it was just her
mom trying to set up the zoom and then
getting her mom our girls grandma is
trying to like so for 10 minutes the
grandmas the camera was turned the wrong
way
so grandma's cameras turn the wrong way
and she just is like do you guys hear
babies so I'm on the couch trying not to
laugh and then all the people are
popping in and then they're trying to
tell her how to do it and then Rachel's
mom is like don't got her glasses on so
she got to get her glasses and then try
to figure it out so 10 minutes we
finally got this [ __ ] started right and
then like you know so the whole her
whole family's there just like 8 9
windows open in the zoom and
and like you know so grandma still don't
gotta figure it out so they're great so
then so then grandma gets the sound on
but but the cameras now facing like her
lap and her desk you know she's like you
know and then she finally turned it
around and everybody's like yay and then
it was just you know Rachel's mom she
she is the best you know so she wants to
sing songs so she's singing like Jewish
hymns you know Jews like to sing y'all I
don't know if y'all ever been to like a
Bar Mitzvah or a Bar Mitzvah
like I didn't know it's it's more soul
at a Jewish ceremony than any black
church okay they in there singing dude
and it's like it's like the leader is
always a dude that like he didn't make
it in the music business
cuz when you go to black church you know
Beyonce might be there cuz this is the
church she grew up at and she coming
back to give back at the Jewish
ceremonies this is a dude who like he
got like a IEP that he never put out he
had a DJ name and then he's like running
the bar mitzvah you don't mean and
singing his ass off you know look I'm
gonna be up there it's good to be back
I'm just turning 13 so we so we doing it
and then like so then her mom singing
and then like somebody wanted to read
something and then like I wish I had
like a piece of paper something so I can
see it like how her grandma was but her
grandma had like like a hymn book of
something and she was holding his [ __ ]
up like this you know and she was
reading it funny bad and I'm just trying
not to laugh you know to read the but it
was it was cool it's actually I'm
laughing about it because it was
actually a really good experience like
I'm not super religious I'm not Jewish
but I appreciated that these people got
together and wanted to uh wanted to keep
the the tradition going like you know if
there's anything that people hate Jews
for for millennia however
people can hate Jews is that they have
these traditions that they being that
they keep and this is one of those
traditions and I thought it was really
nice you know what I mean I thought it
was I thought it was a beautiful thing I
I enjoyed I enjoyed myself you know and
I you know I think my girl enjoyed that
I was I was you know doing it with her I
think I think she really appreciated you
know the effort that I made and and then
we did it two days in a row because so
we had her mother's side of the family
on one day and then it was her father's
side of the family on the next day and
those people were like it was it was and
then Rachel's family is hilarious so
like I don't know if you ever use zoom
so like her dad is like during this
Seder meeting the dads got like
background pictures going
so he's like in Hawaii and if you like
pictures of Rachel love and his wife and
all this kind of stuff you know Rachel
was like I want to put pictures but I
was like we need not that's not going
your pictures you know you never know
you know when you know young girls man
they you know when you're a younger man
you and your early 30s or whatever
however you are you you know what kind
of pictures you got on your phone you
don't want to be bringing up something
by accident but it was fun so I don't
know what you guys did out there let me
go back and see if there's an ego I see
I don't even see if there any questions
I see it but you guys are like going on
and on and on I would like to come to
Toronto so I'm going to chat now people
asking like well you know I don't know
listen first of all I don't know when
we're gonna be back to to go to doing
things yes it's a fake brick wall
[ __ ] I took a picture of my brick
wall and Here I am you know what Brett
Alan in chat your ass is going on
timeout timeout for you talk a [ __ ] you
know to me y'all need to like chill out
okay I'm putting putting fools on
timeout live timeouts you know what we
don't have a timeout song to it's the
time [ __ ] your ass a song time
talk [ __ ] you go on timeout I also
wanted to play for you guys I want to
play for you guys because this is just a
random [ __ ] random ass Griffin what
Griffin live but let me tell you
something like that that I got this dope
these people make songs people send
songs to me from you know they sent them
to the internet site because I use them
on my air Griffin gaming site Eric
Griffin gaming on Twitch and on YouTube
yeah but they send some actually some
dope-ass tracks check this one out
[Music]
[Music]
oh man that's my man cow coos mundo I
think how you come up with that Thunder
are be jams but anyways let me go to
this call that I got for you guys right
now I got this great call that I did
with mr. Pauly Shore he is live from
well he was I called him he was in
Hawaii right now and again guys can you
kind of can you try to be nice I
understand you guys love trolling and
y'all like you know but it's like can we
be positive look I'm coming on live I'm
trying to do extra content I'm trying to
keep it positive you know what I'm
saying and it's just like come on let's
let's do this together as a family you
know what I'm saying so I want you guys
to watch this it's about thirty minutes
just call a poly and then I'm gonna come
back I'm still here I'm gonna come back
on
I might even still be looking at the
chat and then I wanna talk [ __ ] about
bad friends podcast we go go on to their
YouTube if we go look at their [ __ ]
as a podcast set and all that kind of
stuff again so we can check them out
but anyways right now here we go live
from Maui
this is mr. Pauley sure it's funny right
yeah it's very funny it's Pauly Shore I
got you're hilarious
I've already started Pauly so how you
doing I'm doing good I'm all right you
know I'm touching base with different
friends I talked to my friend Jeff
Gravatt this morning he's the old
photographer from back in the day got a
podcast
reminiscing ever
it's kind of reaching out we're all kind
of touching each other without touching
them you know yeah yeah I know we're
trying to write it's like just trying to
stay connected is like we didn't realize
how important it was to be connected
right yeah you know it's um you know
it's uh it's a it's something that no
one ever expected and you know it's
tragedy but you know I think you know it
sounds a little bit weird but I think
when all this is over we're gonna be a
lot more appreciative of the little
things you know that that uh
you know we take for granted so yeah I
totally agree with you I I know exactly
what you're saying I feel the same way
just these little relationships and the
little things like you wonder I remember
when I was younger uh a friend of mine
had died tragically and it was at the
time I thought to myself you know maybe
I'm not I'm not staying connected with
the people that I consider my friend cuz
this just happened nowhere and then I
thought to myself also that I need to
stop having so many people in my circle
like I have so many friends because if
you have so many friends you're not
keeping up with them you're like a bad
friend to many as opposed to being a
good friend to a few yeah yeah how it is
it Sarah you know but you're podcasting
and you know connecting this way at
least at least we have that I mean
imagine being in this epidemic in the
[ __ ] you know in the 70s or [ __ ]
the 40's or something like that know
what the last time it was something like
this was like 1918 if 50 million people
tied you know so it's like ya know what
you mean I think about that - like I'm
so glad we're living in the times that
we're living in where are you right now
I know you're in Hawaii right yeah I
came to Hawaii about three weeks ago I
came here it was so and I might in but
my instincts were to to just get the
[ __ ] out of LA you know I just I just
felt like
walls are closing in and I felt like
there's almost like this almost like a
tornado you know like pretend you're
like living in [ __ ] canvas and you're
like [ __ ] is that a [ __ ] tornado
that's gonna tear us the [ __ ] up and
that's kind of what I felt you know it
happened and you know what it happened
was a March 12th March 12th was really
the day that I felt that oh [ __ ] this
shit's real because I was both looked at
the Oxnard improv for notes and applied
an improv and I sold a good amount on a
ticket it was three o'clock and Cyrus
called me from the improv and uh you
know corporate needs to do or pull the
plug on the show and he kind of knew
there's some [ __ ] going down and I'm
like what you know oh my god like [ __ ]
like this is dawn and then that next
night Friday Saturday I was supposed to
be in La Jolla at the store and then
they pulled the plug on that and that's
when I'm like oh [ __ ] you know and
that's when I was like this is real and
it's gonna get worse yeah March 12th was
um March 12th was my birthday
wait your frozen other year you're back
now yeah March 12th was my birthday and
I was out in Tennessee I'm not like yeah
my 12th birthday
yeah so I was out doing shows in
Tennessee so I did that show the next
day I was still worried it was like
Saturday and I was like God what's
happening and I was hearing from other
people how they'd already like canceled
shows and they were headed home so I
didn't head home till Sunday morning and
at the time I was nervous like am I
gonna make it home and they're gonna
close down domestic travel you know but
you know I made it home and you know
here we are yeah you know develop into
something really nice 17 years my friend
now oh yeah for sure man for sure it's
it's weird how you could be around
people like so frequently you know at
because at the Comedy Store like we see
everyone all the time we kind of kind of
ships in the night you know what I'm
saying like we just
you hear about things but it's not so
you have like certain moments that you
could go oh you know what this is like
somebody that I should actually go
beyond work you know yeah yeah yeah you
see I don't have like you just seem like
you're like got all kinds of things on
your mind right now what are you
thinking about well it's just you know
it's uh it's um I don't know I missed
the end of comedy
I missed the store I miss touring I miss
you know those happy days of being able
to just go to a coffee shop and you know
sit and [ __ ] with people you know and
just kibbutz and and now it's like you
know you can't even sit in the [ __ ]
restaurant so it's kind of sad you know
but that's all I learn how you gonna
wait how you dealing with how you
dealing with that like what do you do to
deal with that those down feelings the
feelings of depression and the feelings
of anxiety how do you deal with it
um I think one day at a time I'm just
trying to get through one day at a time
here and know that someday hopefully
this you know we'll get that call from
the government hey you know you guys are
free to go out or you know so I'm
fortunate you know I put myself in a
position to come out to Maui and you
know there's no tourists here which is
crazy it's like you know I'm like
probably the only tourist on the island
because they're quarantined everyone and
I got out here before that happened so
I'm just fortunate that Asha is my
friend you know she's the person on the
show I met her about three months ago
when I was performing here and we became
friends and we totally get along and
she's really sweet and she has a lot of
you know friends in different places you
know she was born and raised on Maui
though she knows this island like the
back of her hand so it's nice to have
someone like that and and this is Maui
is Maui is a great place to be when
you're in a stressful place you know she
met a few months ago
and then you stayed in contact and now
you're living with her so that's like
that that's like how that's not that
just seems like a reality TV show like
made for TV you know sometimes you meet
people and you get along with them I
mean we've been together every day for
you know since I got here and we just
get along I don't know she's kind of
like a girl version of me she's silly
move just as crazy she's you know she's
uh just cause she's a nice person it's
nice to be around someone like that yeah
that's good man I'm glad I'm glad that
you have that especially that everything
that has gone on in the past year for
you it's like it's like a whirlwind of
stuff you know so now it's like then we
have this I mean I always think about
how it's making everybody's life like
whatever plans you had whatever you
thought was gonna go on out of your head
it's like the world just said nope you
you know imagine if you like imagine if
you just bought a house or you have a
wedding plan or you have like some
birthday I mean there's kids who's got
bar mitzvahs and bar mitzvahs who and
they were supposed to do there's
graduations right now
you know whoever's a senior in high
school right now those eighth graders
all those people those college graduates
they're just right now they're just like
what you know know proms know like it's
like it's it's like I think well I think
we're all collectively like going like
what the [ __ ] how do I do with this yeah
and you know the sports I'm a big sports
person and I know you're a big sports
person you like to go to Clifford you
the Clipper games are so much fun or you
go to games and even watching it on TV
and you know so we'll get we'll get
through it
you know I'm optimistic you know oh
you're paused you do something oh you go
here back sorry the whole the whole
world is going through it so you know
everyone is dealing with it so it's not
just America obviously so right well
come up with something we'll figure it
out Bill Gates it's starting to throw
some cash out so that's cool yeah you
think I mean all these people you know
he's got he's got 50 billion I mean I
think it's like it's like the
those kind of super-rich people them
giving money is only gonna help them
make more money later I mean if there's
no consumers because we can't go out if
there's no people using products you
know their incomes gonna slow down too
so it's like yeah why not
invest about a bunch of money to help us
survive and and get past this I'm
rooting for the scientists I talk to
Dane Cook the other day he said the same
thing you said to me I'm rooting for the
scientist because you know it's like we
want to be able to get in front of
audiences again and we want to
congregate in front of a bunch of people
because that's what we are we're
communal creatures I don't think we're
designed to be cooped up with just one
person or just you know the same person
for a long time but we just we need that
kind of like manic energy of like hey
what's up hey what's up and you know if
you say go into the coffee shop and
laughing and giggling and like being a
being that shows you know what I mean
meeting people that you can go live with
in Hawaii for three months after you
after only three months I mean that's
the only way that would happen is like
you're out in public and you're meeting
and connecting with people
it's like real true connections and it's
hard to do that when you know here we
are like trying to do it like this yeah
it's um the comedy club scene is gonna
be pretty interesting for us once they
let us back I mean we're gonna be
comedians I think are gonna be some of
the most important kind of jobs jobs in
the world because you know I mean dude
darkness there's light you know and this
is a dark time so I think with comics
you know people are gonna want to come
to the clubs and drove and just to laugh
and try to like yeah you know move on
you know so I think we have a big
responsibility all of us well when you
know when when you know when when the
floodgates open again and that the
improv funny bombs the helium's and all
the clubs we workout every week they
alright you guys are back on cuz all of
us are in the same boat we thought our
push to the we got our dates pushed to
the fall you know or August or whatever
I mean every month so we're gonna be
working a lot like in the fall
I think every weekend we're gonna be
[ __ ] books you know
and I think too you know but here's the
one thing I think it's gonna happen to
those all those guys that were doing
like huge theatres they're gonna be
coming back to comedy clubs cuz I don't
think I don't know if those huge
theatres are gonna go open again so
you're gonna have like the big ass yeah
gonna be like at the funny bone doing
like you know ten shows like three shows
Thursday's we show Friday through
Saturday you know so but then hopefully
there will be a wee in it we are gonna
be doing God's work out there making
people laugh even doing these kind of
things man I've gotten a lot of great
messages from people who have been like
hey thanks for doing content I saw a lot
of great messages on your on your show
man about people like oh man you know
that you're putting out something like
that in times like this it's making
people happy it's making people smile
making people distracted you know so you
know good for you man you know so I
think this is also bringing out the true
creator side to a lot of people that you
know not everybody has that not
everybody has the ability to just like
make something out of nothing or
something out of very small things a lot
of people need big budgets and big you
know like some comics need I have to I
can only perform in front of 200 people
I need like a lot of crowds I need I
need the circumstances to be optimal so
the true artists or when circumstances
aren't at their best are really showing
there who they really are so you know
what do you think yeah I mean we have we
have a you know an ability to do things
like this we can create you know thank
God for the Internet and thank God for
YouTube and Instagram and all that stuff
so we can connect and hopefully you know
make people feel better me nuts well we
are the doctors jobs are to operate on
people that are sick and it's our job as
comics to operate on people and make
them feel happy so that's what we do and
that's what you know like the show that
I'm doing out here you know I came up
with the scripted idea and I'm enjoying
it and I feel like I'm busy so it's not
like I'm just willy-nilly yet I'm like
taking my time to come up with it and
then I have a you know camera and
editing and so I feel like
internally I'm feeling like oh [ __ ] like
like least I'm doing something you know
I don't Diego like I want to write joke
right now I don't feel like oh I'm gonna
write some jokes for my stand-up because
I don't know the [ __ ] I'm gonna go back
onstage
oh yeah it's gonna be a tough it's gonna
be a tough couple of weeks when we
finally come back right but you don't
stand it's like you're gonna write jokes
now like great when do you get perform
them yeah usually when we write we write
never like folks it will do them that
night or that weekend will to put them
out or so jokes the way are you writing
down ideas oh just in case you have a
little thought you go bad in the the
post yeah yeah I'm right years and
thought but I'm not getting too much
time on it I'm uh I'm spending more time
on reaching out to friends personally
calling them like Bennet at night I call
out a friend to make sure they're okay
and check-in you know so oh that's good
I talked to Bobby Lee yeah I just talked
to him too I had a I did a podcast
episode with him just recently yesterday
actually yeah yeah so I'm trying to get
I'm trying to catch all my my good buds
and just like you know keep busy I mean
I like doing these kind of things if it
makes me feel like I'm productive like
I'm doing something you know just
everything about me you're getting that
same feeling from doing your show it's
like the writing sending it up it just
makes you feel like okay I'm not doing
nothing I'm actually doing something
it's just so important to feel like that
yeah we'll be up Eric will be alright
you know we got to take care of the
people that aren't alright you know like
the Josh Martens and in those guys that
are the doorman and the guys that are
friends that maybe not you know that
aren't doing as well as maybe we're
doing and you know I gave Josh some
money recently
and you know just take care of people
you know that that maybe aren't doing as
well
what
it's a phone whether it's a little bit
of cash or you know so we'll be alright
we gotta take care of the uber drivers
and the servers and in the [ __ ] uh
you know the people that work paycheck
to paycheck you know those people you
know yeah I agree
those are the people don't think look
those are the people I'm concerned about
but you know um you know right are you
watching TV out there like what are you
doing like what are your hobbies now
like what do you watch by um the other
day
wait you're watching your own movies
I'll tell you what you should do so I
had a lot no but I haven't seen it since
I did it okay listen this is what I
think you should do I think you should
at you pick a time you say like 8
o'clock right and you tell everybody to
turn on biodome at the same time and
then on YouTube you talk while the
movies on and you just you know do like
a DVD commentary but it's live like you
don't mean it's just like you know you
have everybody think okay turn it on and
then like okay and then you we're gonna
watch it together as a unit as a family
what do you think of it when you saw it
I liked it I liked it I liked it a lot
and I and I know why people liked it
because you know obviously that people
come up to me like oh I love biodome so
so I didn't really know why they liked
it so much and then I thought and like
oh they was funny but you know so I
really like biome you know what's your
favorite of your movies favorite movie
yeah what's your favorite movie like if
you had to rank the top three Pauly
Shore movies what are they the ones that
I did or in general the ones you did
Pauly Shore movies you okay well I love
biodome I like son-in-law
she's biodome number one my favorite
right now Oh right now
but I'll probably watch a watch Encino
man and then I'll let you know what I
think about that
Encino man my favorite that's my that's
my go-to that's my go-to poli movies
Encino man yeah I like I like I like the
theme oh man I loved and you know man
you know though and it's cool you know I
mean I'm happy I get those movies and
I'm happy that you know those movies are
living on you know where they're living
on teeth on the platform so that's cool
I also been watching some documentaries
like Netflix it's great you do like you
watch Netflix it's like yeah murderers
killers child abductors takes a pal
murderers killers how the doctors first
writer you know it's like [ __ ] dude they
have so many like murder [ __ ] death
killing serial killer it's like just
criminals Christ you know that's [ __ ]
interested and watching people murder
people or just give them anything yeah
though this all like it seems like the
only good documentaries and ones about
like the whole is if the point of a
documentary is to expose something or to
retell something terrible that happened
it seems to be the only purpose for a
documentary there doesn't seem to be any
other purpose but if you don't do
there's no comedy documentary abut cuz
even comedy documentaries maybe those
are that's why there's not allow those
because they're so boring
yeah there's a I don't know I mean yeah
obviously we talked about the tiger king
obviously everyone likes that because
it's so [ __ ] weird right weird but but
other than that I don't know you know I
think if it was me I think it was no IDs
those those are the kinda you would have
went over there you would had a MTV crew
and you would have been you would have
went to that Zoo you know what I mean
back in the day I'm sure those guys are
big colleagues or fear
[Laughter]
that's your crowd cult cult leader
animal people exotic animal lover some
of my shows at the igor tampa improv for
sure it feels like that
[Laughter]
so you just what documentaries have you
watched recently though that made you
like go what the [ __ ] going on besides
that one no what what documentaries have
you been watching that made you like
even think about that
I saw the one I saw the one last night I
forgot what it's called but it was so
[ __ ] up dude it was so [ __ ] up it
was the values of ms it was a Cossack
chemist yes they in Boston dude
wasn't it [ __ ] bananas that was yeah
that one's um it's called a something
drug scandal
wait I'll look it up I have it right
here I know I saw that one too and that
one was I thought that was just so
bizarre and then like for the result to
be that like 35,000 and people were let
out of prison or something like that had
their head there had their sentences
vacated I mean that [ __ ] was bananas
dude but these [ __ ] chemists was
doing the drug they're so smart she's
doing the math and the other chick is
not even [ __ ] checking to see if it's
cocaine or not just like marking it gone
yeah that's fine click [ __ ] if your job
is to test it to see if it's [ __ ]
cocaine or not so terrible there's
people like you know sitting here
waiting you know I don't know who was
worse without you think was worse the
one doing the drugs or the other one
that lied about her whole life who was
worse to you the one the one that was
lying about her whole life or the one
that was you know doing the drive think
the Indian [ __ ] I think the Indian
[ __ ] was [ __ ] work yeah could at
least trying to do her job just she was
just doing drugs like she had
to do her job so she could do two drugs
like she had to make sure it was cocaine
cuz she was trying to smoke okay yeah
she was she was doing the drug so that's
okay you know she's a drug addict you
know like you can kind of excuse the
drug addict because you know drug
addicts like you know a [ __ ] drug
addict but that other [ __ ] she wasn't
even [ __ ] testing it she's like yeah
that's good that's good that's good and
they're gone why did she go frat I don't
even think she had proper education
either that one chick right I don't
think she lied about her education she
just she just got the job and they just
kind of they just let that slide I was
like what is going on in Boston right
now or whenever that whenever that was
going on yeah but that was a weird
documentary it was like I don't know if
it was sad I don't know if it was like
it just was kind of like dammit this was
going on you kind of feel like like do
you watch a documentary like that you
think like what's going on everywhere
what's one said I why I thought the
Aaron Hernandez one was pretty good the
Aaron Hernandez one that was pretty good
what what the Aaron Hernandez you know
the guy from the guy was convinced that
was great everything's [ __ ] up in
Boston dude yeah yeah that's all my god
you're right I just realized that that
guy was in Boston too so it's hard to
you got your gloves
what mask you're just pulling you
pulling your crazy I got I got my math
you go out with the math yeah I have a
scarf I'm using my scarf because they
say that the math you know we should
donate those to medical professionals
yeah there you go that's how you should
do that what about that you look like
you were white Zorro hey thank you for
doing myself that was funny dude he
played the character of my best friend
Leonard from the gym yeah it was a good
one that's Alfred that's out right now
check it out
volley tours quarantine with my ex on
Maui
Griffin is on the episode right now
playing Leonard my best friend I had sex
with your that was like real [ __ ] coming
out of here like you really felt like I
[ __ ] over
I was just channeling some past bad
experiences did you hit did you ever
have a did you ever have one of your
friends have sex with your ex-girlfriend
no I've never had that but I had had an
ex cheat on me I've been cheated on
before and that's just not a good
feeling
you know just I've just been to you you
think you've had that bad experiences
too haven't you can you hear me right
yeah I think it sounds a little we can
you hear me I can hear you great don't
worry about it I'm just using a time
using a computer Mike that's why it's
coming down but my sound my real sounds
going into this so you just gonna sound
great and I'm getting a good enough
sound from you that it's gonna be okay
you know what I mean
so don't don't worry about it I'll speak
louder I notice you have it I noticed
you have a green screen what behind it
nothing's behind it I just that's just a
wall so cuz like right now how I'm gonna
do it is my little my little self is
gonna be on your screen like in your
kitchen like right there like I'm gonna
be next to you on the screen you know so
that's that's I just green screen myself
out and put it put it right there that's
what I do then I just move myself what
are you looking what are you gonna put
behind it you know man no I could if I
wanted to but it'll just be you I'm just
gonna put it like I'm gonna be in there
with you your backgrounds gonna be my
background all right yeah how's it been
going how's it been going doing the
podcast like I've just started to record
a bunch of them now you know cuz it's
just is still fresh and I do I put them
out once a week so now I'm starting to
do like more I'm trying to do two a week
I'm trying to put out more content just
for the people just more content because
the people want to consume it and so I
think it's going good I guess I mean but
what other choice do I have
you know yes I would still like to have
people come sit in my podcast area but
you know it is what it is I just want to
keep putting out con
and you know you know it just it just
stay creative I mean that's really the
thing is like I just want to feel
creative you know so I admire more what
you're doing I doing like the characters
and the fake you know the fake situation
and you know being so you know it's like
yesterday I was like oh good I can act
again you know what I mean you know you
say yeah that's what you want to do you
want to perform you know I mean and even
people that have regular yeah
like we like to act I'm not acting you
know like podcasting coolest and of cool
but I love acting you know acting for my
favorite you know what is our movie
gonna come out is that even gonna what
is that just everything on hold with
that what's the deal no everything's
good with that movie that movies come
that movies gonna be coming out I'll let
you know soon but because of everything
that went it's been going on everything
got a little shaky you know but it's
coming out and everyone's really excited
about it I don't want to tell you the
name of the company but it's a pretty
big company that picked it up and I'll
know any second any day they're gonna
tell me once the ink the sign on the
contract
you know then will they just go probably
if this still is going on right now
they're just gonna go direct to like
Netflix or something like that or what
are they gonna do you know yeah I don't
know you know I want them to take it out
now because everyone's at home you know
I mean you know hopefully and then I
guess I can wonder I mean if you have to
watch biodome you know even you're like
what am I gonna watch I guess I watch
biodome you didn't mean so you mean
you're out there like looking for
something to watch so this is it right
now this is gonna be the resurgence did
you see how louis c.k put out a special
yes I did I started watching it it's
very funny
I haven't finished but I heard at the
end F when he talked about the
masturbation with the girl so uh we
saved it for the end so you paid for it
I don't know if I wanted I was like I
don't know if I want to pay for I don't
like I'll text it to you I have a copy
oh please
there we go there it is yeah send me
that [ __ ] I want to I want to check it
out affected the affected here but it's
the best way to do it you know you have
your you anybody should be like that you
don't need anyone I mean y-you don't
mean we don't need anyone to put out our
content anymore this guy was like on the
ground floor of that you know he was he
was one of the first guys to like make a
special himself and sell it on his own
website he did that he was the one of
the first guys to do that so all of us
we don't need we don't need Netflix or
any of these places we just want it
because it feels good to be wanted but
other than that it's like put out your
content you're doing it you know we all
can put out our own yeah because more
people if it's good more people with
Garrett than anything you know yeah yeah
for sure
that's that I mean that's where we're at
right now I'm a little jealous that
you're in Hawaii though like are you
keeping active like are you walking
around the beach oh what's open or not
open what are you doing let me say let
me tell you my backyard what's that at
least you've got on the show oh nice
look at the Wow
paulie's just living the life right now
there looks like some sort of that looks
like you're living in a national park
nobody's going into pool though how's
the pool off there's no one there's no
one around no one's around oh is that
like are you not stinking standing like
a is it like a Resort Hotel type of
thing no it's a it's like the condo if
the condo that lives on on a golf court
Oh
so people rent those things out just
nobody's there Wow we need you Paulie
come stay here hilarious
well look dude I don't want to keep you
too long I just wanted to call check in
with you and see how you doing you know
I'm you seem to be doing all right you
seem to be handling this well I keep
telling everybody that I talked to it's
okay to feel whatever you're feeling
like
we're all gonna feel a little depressed
and anxious and we're gonna feel like
we're lost but you know it's okay to
have those feelings we just have to deal
with them the best way we can exercise
exercise that's the main thing exercise
you hear first from Paul you gotta
exercise what else also say so say some
final thoughts to the people man so we
can what's the final thoughts from mr.
Pauly Shore well just know that this
will end think of it it you know most of
us have never been to prison but think
of it as as this is our time in prison
or allowed outside a couple times a day
but mostly were we're staying inside so
most prisoners when they get thrown in
jail they have two choices number one
they're at peace and they found Jesus
and they're studying or number two
they're in solitary confinement and
they're throwing feces on the time the
cell so where are you at in the process
[Laughter]
I talk to you soon brother and safe yeah
there was y'all mr. Pauly Shore live
from what way it wasn't live but he was
live when I recorded that from from
Hawaii so I hope you guys enjoyed that
you know I mean and again you will be
don't talk to my [ __ ] before I talk [ __ ]
about bad French podcasts I thought I
actually show you guys my Netflix like
what I'm watching you know let's do that
real quick this is what's going on with
me yeah so check out my Netflix I'm
watching this show money heist it's
actually pretty good that's a pretty
good show and then I started watching
alter calm carbon but I but I didn't I
didn't steal [ __ ] but I didn't stop it
I'm a didn't I stopped it you know I
mean cuz it just wasn't
like why is it doing it like the other'
buddy I gotta stopped it there we go
yeah so I started watching altered
carbon Hernandez I've left a little bit
of Pete Davidson special you know that
is what it is and then you know black
mirror I you know I didn't know why that
showed Oaks I never watched that I
started watching that movie doom it just
sucked and then here's these things
popped on Netflix I don't know what I
want to watch but this is what my
Netflix looks like it's crazy I want to
watch this Chappelle thing it's Mark
Twain Awards I'm gonna check that out
I'm not gonna check out community I
never liked community when the [ __ ] was
on a hundred humans live questions I
want to check that out I like some of
these things on here I don't know what
this one's about unorthodox I'm on with
the man might have to check that one out
I think my girl started watching that
one I want to watch the stranger I don't
know but that's what I'm some of the
things I'm watching on Netflix I don't
know what you guys are watching on
Netflix anybody got any anybody got any
recommendations from for me on Netflix I
am in the chat and you will I will put
your time out I have a quick timeout
trigger let's be nice for this last 10
20 minutes you know you know okay guys
let's just keep it keep our minds right
you know I'm saying I want no nonsense
yeah we got like ten more minutes y'all
just want to do a solid hour we just
answer any questions the stuff that's
going it all so on so somebody said
unorthodox is a pretty interesting
letter to the king all right I'll check
that one out you know what I should
watch workaholics I haven't watched
workaholics in the long ass time I
should actually check that out I should
go on there and be let's see what what's
going on with workaholics I got it I'm
trying to get the guys to get on a call
with me too on ders Adam and Blake but
they bougie as hell man this is
impossible to get those [ __ ] on a
call Thank You PO you will do it man
we'll do it then I just never hear from
them you know I mean I know I should
call Santino's ass I wish I had it set
up for that I would just do a quick
FaceTime you know what next week I'll do
that they just hang up on his ass like
he hangs up on me all the time
but anyway
actually speaking of let's go over to
and see let's go over and see what we
got going on here with the good old bad
friends yeah yeah terrible friends
podcast I mean look at this [ __ ] dude
let's just should we listen in on this
was like episode I don't even know what
episode this was but should we to be
listening for a second you would come
this way mr. Jones right and they would
sit there on the bed yes and you know
what I would do I would smoke the opium
and then it'd make you suck my dick look
at this [ __ ] is set man every time I see
this set dude I'm just like what the
hell is going on but they're doing okay
the podcast is doing good I'm not gonna
hate it's just this set is ridiculous is
this them doing social distancing
wearing gloves and like whatever all the
[ __ ] do they have on she's not sense man
this is you know and then look at their
sponsor right there oh god I'm just I'm
helping them out not even helping me out
these people [ __ ] got a Lucky Charms
box on his damn desk like what the hell
is that
I know Bobby has zero muscles right
there a zoom in on Bobby let's see we
get a zoom in on Bobby yeah look at this
guy this is Bobby right now this is
Bobby right now telling people you know
don't do it it's [ __ ] [ __ ] gloves
I mean just this guy's such a character
you know what I mean look at him he's
just such a character I don't even know
what to really say about him you know
this is my good friend I think he
sometimes a little too mean to me
about me you know I mean but you know it
is what it is but anyways hope you guys
are doing good any last minute questions
or anything like that any any
suggestions any recommendations for
shows to watch
I know I should do my react I should do
reaction videos of bad friends every
week but I think there's already people
out there doing that being like super
negative so I don't want to be a super
negative guy because I love those dudes
so I'm not trying to like be a hater I'm
not trying to be a hater
how do I have a dad bod and no kids
that's terrible
that's just rude man yes Bobby
the friendship it can be tested however
have I ever pulled any pranks on Santino
no I don't know he told the story about
the shrimp and that is exactly actually
what happened we were taking because we
were we were taking pictures forecasts
pictures for it I'm dying up here and
they wouldn't let us eat until we took
our picture and for some reason I'm
closer to the end and in my mind I was
like think I'll run out of food because
everybody kept coming in with the food
that they had it was a good-ass shrimps
and other kind of stuff so when I went
up to the thing and I was like I was so
ready and then to do was like sorry sir
we're out of food and I was like I knew
it I just went off and then the guy like
I was so mad that the guy blew it the
guy that travels like any other guy told
me to tell me and I knew exactly who it
was he said and I was like and of course
everybody else knew yes I'm gonna have
my next episode on riffing with Griffin
on Saturday the audio will come out is
with I called Bobby and I'll thank um
Jan Bobby and the YouTube video will
come out on Monday that would be my
regular schedule and I may or may not
put out a bonus episode on all man you
guys coming with the super chat so I
appreciate it Carlos and mr. Chan oh you
know we do we get super chance we see
photo stupid chats and change
Carlos Noble evening this is neighbor
I'm not sure and the guy Ryan from
earlier alright um yes I'm gonna have
Rick Glassman on for sure I love Rick we
always have fun with the right when Rick
comes on um I want to watch that make
millions i'ma check out that make
millions I know how you tell you guys
what I think about that [ __ ]
oh this Cheers by the way this chair is
comfortable as hell you know if you go
to Eric Griffin gaming on YouTube just
any one of those videos even in the in
the description I have a code you can
get a really good discount and I have a
commercial on there there's a really
good discount for the cheer if you're
still interested in getting two chairs
really comfortable it's got the lumbar
support so I love that yeah and I
appreciate all the super chat love you
know are you guys are you guys are great
you know I'm trying to come live cuz I'm
bored as [ __ ] just like you are and it's
not just because I'm bored it's just
also because I just want to feel
connected you know so I know y'all a lot
of you in here in the chat just talking
[ __ ] and just being a mess but I
actually like it you know I just I feel
like I feel like all of us right now
everybody that's watching live right now
how many people there's like 378 people
watching right now according to my thing
and I just want to tell you guys that
you know I appreciate it you know what I
mean
I appreciate know there's Jay I wasn't
Ryan it was Jeff there's just
Jame can say your name
don't forget about Jeff you know what I
mean so I appreciate that and you know
look at us we just like we just do a
little community you know so I'll keep
coming live on Fridays maybe [ __ ]
maybe I do a live every night at 8:00 I
don't know if it gets to the point where
I gotta you know keep doing it but you
know I'm having fun doing this and it
just makes me feel creative makes me
feel like I'm like doing what I was
doing before makes me feel like a little
bit normal and I know you guys are out
there and you have in trouble I know you
out there some of you are like just
depressed you're not sure what the
[ __ ] going on
you know just stay strong stay you stay
diligent let's just keep the social
distancing and you know we'll be able to
bounce back we've come back from worse
you know in our and especially in the
United States we've gone through some a
lot of terrible times in the United
States and this is just one of those
times that we'll look back and be like
damn remember when we couldn't touch
anybody and remember when that virus was
killing people but you know I hope and
if anybody out there is it has been
touched by this you know like your one
degree away from it like you had a
relative that died my condolences go to
you and for all of us that even know
someone that has been I think all of us
at this point knows someone that has
been sick I think we all know someone
that is like I got it and I recovered or
I got it or they or their father got or
somebody got it and you know so let's
you know that's that's that's let's stay
strong because that's what's needed
right now stay strong and I got nothing
but love for all you guys oh wait a
minute
little Dickie went to sue
all right let's go out with um let's get
some more songs on here that I got from
people I got some dis about you know why
don't we stay with my guy Kyle cos mundo
Kyle's dope he got some dope tracks on
here and that's it right there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I know I do need to make a diss track
that's what I should do
make a diss track against punk-ass and
Joe and Bobby yes we do this rights will
write some lyrics together alright last
one and then I'm out
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on one thank y'all for watching
subscribing please subscribe and share
and do all that good stuff
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
belly button
[Music]
[Music]
hilarious all right you guys I'm sure
that's gonna be clipped you order first
I appreciate all you guys and thanks for
watching and like I say be safe out
there love hug your loved ones that
don't have coronis you know stay
connected with the people that you can't
stay connected with call your friends
listen to podcast help people out
you know shout out to all those
frontline workers fit fireman policeman
and all those people I appreciate the
work that you guys do and also the
people that deliver groceries and all
that kind of stuff make sure make sure
you guys you know look out for them too
so tip heavy you know what I mean they
deserve tips and just help people out as
much you can and I love you guys and I
appreciate you guys being here with me
this whole time
alright peace out